the Joe Rogan experience so Jamie Vernon
has some Facebook stock for sale he's
got he's uploaded it to Craig's old take
it take it off my hands
I think it'll bounce back if you guys
don't know what we're talking about
Facebook
apparently Jamie you were the one who
first told me about it once you fill in
well from what I saw there's something
going on I think the company is called
Cambridge analytic which what I've also
then learned is that Steve Bannon used
to be the VP of this company but that
was before he was in the Trump campaign
yeah they are responsible for scraping
millions of users personal information I
think through a couple apps maybe like a
like a personality app if someone took a
personality quiz right look at those
online clickbait polls
yeah so but let's be those are morons
that answer those things right for the
most part or people are super bored and
that's how you get most of the time how
you get your facebook like passwords
stolen is from those things oh yeah yeah
or from sneaky emails to tell you your
accounts been compromised please reenter
your password well it doesn't say
Facebook on the URL they they can be
sneaky with their URLs to like put
something in front of it and then
Facebook and you're like ah looks like
Facebook you know so the FTC is looking
into this case right now apparently as
of yesterday and what I read is they
face up to potentially 40,000 dollar
fine for every infraction which would
total over two million two trillion
dollars I'm sorry the tea trillion so
it's theirs their stock has tanked I
think it was like 8% yesterday it's at 8
and a half so far today it's down to 165
dollars a share it was like a hundred
eighty-five two days ago
so and then a lot of people then are
also not talking about just getting rid
their Facebook account altogether
I talked about this last night I'm on
the actual offense of doing that just
because I can't take it anymore that's
the only place I go to where it's just I
get annoyed I get in fights I have to
see my sister talk about Trump every day
you know like it's just I get it's just
upsetting now it's a very good forum for
people that are into political arguments
like political arguments
gay rights arguments there's a lot of
like that's like one of the last places
where it's okay to say that you don't
think gay people should be married yes
it's like you know I know I just know
some people that I probably shouldn't
know anymore
yeah and occasionally you know we're on
my real Facebook page which I never go
to look if I go to it once a year it's a
lot and that's where all the fake news
stuff is like I thought Pam Anderson
died the other day and it was just one
of those fake news stories and that's
always where you find it is on Facebook
whenever you go and read an article and
those those things at the bottom they're
like you should see what she looks like
now and there's like 30 of them like
wait a minute like they just throw and
[ __ ] at you they just literally elect
come on you're gonna bite on one of
these come on what is it a Kevin Costner
you can't believe what he looks like now
remember that girl from precious you
can't believe it does it work though
check so every so often no I don't need
more I'd say got me a few times in the
early days I thought that those were
below see it's a sneaky thing because
they took the place of real stories it's
like it used to you go to CNN and
everything would be CNN but now you go
to CNN everything's CNN up until a line
and then below the line it's like
sponsored content like wait wait wait
this isn't this is so sneaky because
this is barely an ad this is like an
article on CNN that takes you to some
new place and every page like you have
to keep changing pages and every page is
like one paragraph like one paragraph on
what Kevin Costner was like in 1980 okay
yeah what about 81 boom next page an 81
Kevin Costner started to gain weight
yeah and then there's usually not the
photo that you want to see you know how
like that thumbnail has like Kevin
Costner's head blowing apart you're like
I want to see that picture right it's
not even in there it's fake clickbait
yeah that is that and snapchat I think
should go I might be out done with those
two does snapchat Rihanna Chris Brown
thing is crazy the fact that somebody
greenlit that it cost them almost a
billion dollars like instantly weren't
they down like some eight hundred
million dollars or some [ __ ] insane
number yeah I mean I was yeah the second
time that's happened in a couple weeks
yeah
one of them was like Kylie Jenner saying
it sucks right yeah the hottest
Kardashian so 800 million they dropped
after Rihanna condemned ad making light
of domestic violence so the question was
in that poll
would you rather slap Rihanna or punch
Chris Brown like what oh gee maybe this
look at that of course everyone wants to
punch like what's the slap Rihanna
there's a lot of dudes there's a lot of
[ __ ] out there there's got to be
probably a sizable percentage of the
people clicked slap Rihanna just cuz
they don't like their life well [ __ ] the
[ __ ] I would like to see that with the
results where of this yeah well you
would have to join the abandoned
administration and they get you involved
in Cambridge analytics and you gotta
give up your fingerprints I don't know
how anybody could say yeah put that on
snapchat like that seems so [ __ ]
insane that seems like a joke like in a
movie you know well like you talk about
like a clueless executive you know like
this is my idea what do you think lots
of clicks
lots of clicks you know cut to him with
a sad face holdings boxes stuff as he's
being kicked out of his office and stay
out you know he doesn't seem like
something that something is huge is
snapchat how could they do that
they've been [ __ ] I mean the whole
redesign they did recently it already
was confusing and annoying to begin with
but don't use it at all
now it's even worse and like everything
even had a website where you know every
a petition to switch back I think they
got up to a million users saying we want
the old snapchat back in there right now
it's it's better now we're not listening
to you oh well Instagram listened right
they went back to things being in
chronological order did they do that
they tested it I was like a beta test
that hasn't happened for everyone yet
but it probably will happen or it's
gonna become an option soon yeah nobody
likes this nonsense I look at my feed
from real recent and it says I'll look
at someone's post I was like this is
yesterday and then I look at the time it
says 26 hours ago I'm like what in the
[ __ ] is that hey why are you showing me
something from a day ago yeah like or
I'm gonna be here tonight and that was
from like three days ago 30
this concert
[Applause]